The marching band is holding a
raffle at a football game with
two prizes.
After the first ticket is pulled
out and the winner
determined, the ticket is
taped to the prize.
The next ticket is pulled out to
determine the winner of the
second prize.
Are the two events
independent?
Explain.
Now before we even think about
this exact case, let's think
about what it means for events
to be independent.
It means that the outcome of one
event doesn't affect the
outcome of the other event.
Now in this situation, the first
event-- after the first
ticket is pulled out and the
winner determined-- the ticket
is taped to the prize.
Then the next ticket is pulled
out to determine the winner of
the second prize.
Now, the winner of the second
prize-- the possible winners,
the possible outcomes for the
second prize, is dependent on
who was pulled out for
the first prize.
You can imagine if there's
three tickets, let's say
there's tickets A, B,
and C in the bag.
And for the first prize,
they pull out ticket A.
That's for the first prize.
Now, when we think about who
could be pulled out for the
second prize, it's only going
to be tickets B or C.
Now the first prize could
have gone the other way.
It could have been
A, B, and C.
The first prize could have
gone to ticket B.
And then the possible outcomes
for the second prize
would be A or C.
So the possible outcomes for
the second event, for the
second prize, are completely
dependent on what happened or
what ticket was pulled out
for the first prize.
So these are not independent
events.
The second event-- the outcomes
for it, are dependent
on what happened in
the first event.
So they are not independent.
The way that we could have
made them independent is,
after the first ticket was
pulled out, if they just wrote
down the name or something,
and then put
that ticket back in.
Instead they taped
it to the prize.
But if they put that ticket
back in, then the second
prize, it would have still had
all the tickets there.
It wouldn't have mattered who
was picked out in the first
time because their name was just
written down, but their
ticket was put back in.
And then you would have
been independent.
So if you had replaced the
ticket, you would have been
independent.
But since they didn't replace
the ticket, they taped it to
the prize, these are not
independent events.